[Music]
on average you produce just over two
kilograms of waste every day that may
not sound like a whole lot but multiply
it by every person on earth and suddenly
you've got 14 point eight billion
kilograms of waste being produced every
24 hours but what would happen if we
suddenly stopped recycling with the
world be quickly flooded with garbage
would we fire it into space this is what
if and here's what would happen if
everyone stopped recycling nearly
everything we buy has some recyclable
component glass paper plastic metal and
other materials the United States
recycles about 65 million tons of waste
each year which is just 30% of it's 200
million tons of yearly waste around the
world recycling as a massive industry
countries in Europe like Austria and
Germany recycle over 50% of their waste
every year now what would happen if
everyone in the planet just decided to
stop if the world stopped recycling
every single scrap of waste would end up
in a landfill well most of it with a
larger amount of trash it's inevitable
that we'd get more in places where it
shouldn't be at first you probably
wouldn't notice anything in a best-case
scenario most landfills around the world
expect to last 30 to 50 years one of
America's largest landfills began
accepting garbage back in 1957 and
finally stopped in 2013 that's 56 years
of trash it may take a couple of years
even decades before garbage starts
piling up everywhere so what happens
when those landfills finally fill up
when landfills become too full to take
on anymore garbage they're covered with
clay and soil to form large hills you
might think the job is done at that
point that you'll never need to think
about that stinky garbage ever again but
sadly that isn't the case while the
garbage is tightly packed underground it
remains in an oxygen 'less environment
there it creates methane gas a huge
contributor to global warming landfills
are the third largest producers of
methane gas in the world and as the
planets landfills continue to fill they
have the potential to eclipse farming
and fossil fuel production and become
the highest
producers with our landfills full where
would the rest of our garbage go well we
wouldn't blast it up into space that's
far too expensive instead we'd most
likely burn it a practice that some
European countries are currently doing
however if every landfill did this it
would create even more potentially
deadly pollution making the air we
breathe
toxic recycling prevents almost 200
million metric tons of greenhouse gases
from polluting our environment each year
that's the equivalent of the fumes
produced by over 39 million cars on the
highway a lot of our trash would end up
in places where it's not supposed to go
like the ocean right now the world's
oceans are home to millions of floating
pieces of plastic with no one recycling
even more of this debris would end up in
the water killing millions of fish and
making the water unswerving but these
might be the least of our worries at
least in the short term what we would
start to notice quickly would be our
natural resources being destroyed you
see recycling isn't just about keeping
trash out of landfills it also helps us
sustain our natural resources like
timber it's estimated nearly 7 billion
trees are cut down globally each year in
2017 the United States recycled over 68
million tons of paper without this more
trees would have to be cut down to
sustain the paper supply leading to an
even higher amount of deforestation than
we have today you can say goodbye to
fossil fuels in addition to making our
cars go they're the source of all our
plastic products fossil fuels are
currently expected to deplete by 2050
but without recycling fossil fuel
consumption would be higher than ever
leading to the precious resource being
gone much sooner so with no one
recycling the world would have no choice
but to change for instance new water
bottles being researched today are being
made out of biopolymer a material that's
composed of bacteria these bottles are
designed to biodegrade in just 18 months
that would help a lot as the world is
currently using over a million plastic
water bottles per minute other materials
and products would eventually have to
follow suit maybe one day we'll live in
a world where everything is
biodegradable even electronics but
that's a story for another
what if
[Music]